last time we talked about the idea of um
anthropomorphized is that the right word
I think it is Robo prored robot
proris yes um creatures creatures
running around anyway doing doing jobs
for us doing tasks for us and where
where do we go from here then that's
right so yeah um yeah last time as you
say we had I made up this uh robot thing
which really came from like a 1980s book
that I had as a kid and lots of us did
that that showed how computers worked by
showing how robots move around and did
things inside and we had this idea of a
robot with a little Abacus which was his
way of doing any arithmetic that you
asked of him and he had only a very
limited amount of resources available to
him he had a little card that he had
like the most recent number that he
worked on the accumulator and he had a
little tag that he could use to say
where he was and where he was was in
this big set of pigeon holes which it
occurs to me most folks these days
probably don't know what a pigeon hole
is um so yeah it's like the male boxes
in like a shared apartment you know
you've got this big grid of boxes and
you know you can say well this number is
for address zero and we said addresses
last time as well addresses are like the
which number box we're looking in and
inside each of those boxes we can put
one these pieces of card that has a
number on it as well and we were we able
to use that to build pretty much
anything and right at the end we showed
that the very program the instructions
to the robot could be put inside those
pigeons holes itself which then kind of
like completes the circle if we like but
I glossed over a lot of things and so
today I'd like to talk a little bit
about how math is done inside the
computer and how we can sort of solve
the problem of carrying on
forever last time we talked about this
accumulator where the robot could write
numbers on and do maths with his Abacus
and that's all cool and all but really
there's a limited amount of resources
that the robot has he can't write
arbitrarily large numbers like we were
doing last time last time we were sort
of adding them up and we were putting
thousands and whatever inside each of
these boxes and that's not what
computers can do they are limited in how
the big the number they can represent is
and in the age of the 1980s where my my
heart still is the most computers that
you could get access to were 8bit
computers and the 8 Bits refers to
essentially the amount of data that was
natural for the computer to deal with at
a time either the amount it could fetch
from memory at one point in time or the
kind of size of numbers that it could
add together uh 8 Bits in my robot world
will be effectively two digits so I'm
not going to use binary because it gets
a little bit complicated uh we'll talk a
little bit about that hopefully if we
get time at the end but as a sort of
near enough approximation what I'm going
to do is use two digigit numbers and so
really our little accumulator it can
store from
0 oh I can't even write and it can do 01
02 all the way up to 99 so we get 100
different values and that's okay all
right similarly our little set of pigeon
holes each one of those uh um slots in
the pigeon hole can only also store a
two-digit number that seems a bit
limiting because Fibonacci numbers grow
if we were sorry last time we write a
little program to to generate Fibonacci
numbers that's where my mind is but they
grow very quickly and they get over 100
pretty swiftly so the natural tradeoff
is how can we teach our robot how to do
maths involving more than one value at a
time so that we can say use four digits
by putting the numbers in consecutive
pigeon holes similarly our robot can
only do simple MTH with his Abacus
involving two two-digit numbers now how
as humans would we add two two-digit
numbers together well actually the same
kind of thing that we do when we're
adding any kind of numbers together
let's say 10 and 33 as a human I start
with the right hand this is at least how
I was taught to do it the kids these
days probably have taught something else
column Edition I think column Edition
exactly and we start from the right hand
side so I add 0 + three and it gives me
three and I add one and three and it
gives me four and So my answer is 43 and
I could just keep doing this if I had
more digits I could just keep adding
them on to this side so if this was 1,0
and uh 2133 this would be 31 43 and so
on so we could keep on making that
number arbitrary large as large as my
piece of paper and Patience are but pick
these numbers cuz they're low what
happens if I add say
99 with another
99 well 9 + 9 is 18 so how I'd write it
is 8 carry 1 and now we've got um this
is now a 10 uh and then 10 + 9 is 9 and
with an extra one we got one more digit
and we had to do a Carry operation there
was a carry out of there because we got
a bigger number than we could write down
in in any one column now our robotss got
two columns at a time um but we need to
teach him how to carry so we're going to
add some facilities to the robot he's
going to have a little bit of extra um
state so at the moment he's only got an
accumulator the index which we talked
about before and now we're going to give
him a set of flags now that's a silly
name but it's what they're called so I'm
going to kind of go with the metaphor
because they're kind of nice as well and
the flags are either raised little flag
that's up or not raised or down or clear
so we e Clear or set or raised or or
lowered however you want to think of it
like that but if you want to think of
them as physical Flags they're raised
and lowered and the robot has about a
half dozen of them the one that we're
import we're interested in is the carry
flag and so he has a little flag up here
this is might with a a c on it which is
probably too s small to see other flags
the robot might have are
zero and negative and overflow and other
things like that and essentially every
time the robot does some arithmetic he
sets the values of these flags according
to what happened so if he adds two
two-digit numbers together and gets a
carry he raises the carry flag else he
makes sure it's put down and that's his
way of remembering at the back of his
head that if he needed to carry on and
do some more arithmetic then maybe he
has to account for an extra uh an extra
one that we're going to add in similarly
the zero flag is set if the result of
what the robot just calculated is zero
the zero flag is set otherwise it's
cleared the negative is if it goes below
zero which my decimal setup doesn't work
very well with I'll be honest with you
but so I'm going of gloss over that
overflow again more complicated and
there are some other flags the robot
might have that are to do with some of
the other things that that the computer
has to deal with but our carry in this
instance lets us write code now that
looks a little bit like this so I'm
going to sort of go back to writing the
assembly code which is the human
readbook sort of human readable version
of how to add larger numbers together
and so if for example in our Fibonacci
number uh Fibonacci program we wanted to
add uh say four digit numbers together
let's make a decision that all of the
numbers are going to be four digits what
I'm going to do is I'm going to use two
pigeon holes for every number that's
going to be in the sequence the part
before where we were just adding the two
prior numbers together to get the next
number has to be a little bit more
complicated and I'm not going to go over
the whole program because it's a lot but
we're just going to write a little bit
of how you might add two two-digit
numbers together so the first thing I
need to do is add the least significant
that is in our case the right hand digit
of the number now we get to a point
where computers have Schism because
there are two different ways of doing
this one way is that we store the least
significant number first in memory
because it's the one you need first if
you're about to do arithmetic on it
however that has the side effect of
writing the number backwards in memory
now if you never look at the memory you
don't care about that you always read it
consistently but if you're debugging a
program and you're looking at the bites
in memory one after another the numbers
Look Backwards for some definition of
backwards and so it's convenient for
computers but a pain for humans those
computers are called little endian
because the little like the least
significant part of the number is stored
first so the end of the number is like
the little end comes first um as it
happens that seems to have won out so
the the the the CPU that we're on here
on my my uh my laptop is an Intel one
that is little Indian uh most arm chips
are a little Indian they can be
configured um but the main frames of of
the time were big Indian they were the
other way around and anyway so that's
little Indian and big endian as a bonus
bit of content in here so anyway we're
going to store them little Indian so
that means that we're going to load the
first number so first I need to clear
the carry to make sure that whatever had
happened before I don't want to add in
an extra from a previous operation there
is no previous operation and now I'm
going to load a value into the
accumulator so I'm going actually like
let's let's do let's do an actual
operation here oops let me get my little
index pointer out and I'm going to draw
a little subset over here of the pigeon
holes and we don't even need to know
what index these pigeon holes are
because it's all relative to this index
that we're about to write so this is the
index which is currently pointing to or
referring to the first of the two
numbers I want to add together and I'm
going to put the result over here in
these two sections
two little slots over here let's go with
some numbers that actually are Fibonacci
233 and 377 are some Fibonacci numbers I
think they're 14 and 15 something like
that so again in little Indian World
we're going to store the least
significant two digits first so of the
233 that means I'm going to write 33 in
this first box and I'm going to write
02 in the second box so again you can
sort of see that it's confusing 233
reading sort of right to left two digits
at a time and then the next one is uh
377 okay now we want to add the 33 and
the 77 together so what I want to do is
I want to refer relative to this index
so while we're here I'm going to teach
my robot that you don't have to keep
moving this index around all the time
like we did in the last episode um what
we can do is just have relative to this
index so I'm going to say load the
number at the index plus Z I.E the one
where it's actually pointing out right
now so that would have loaded into our
accumulator let's get our accumulator 33
so the number in the accumulator is now
33 and our little carry flag is down now
we're going to say
add and I'm just because I'm changing
this to include a carry I'm going to
call it add with carry a
DC whatever is pointed at x + 2 so
rather than moving the index two forward
and then two back as I'm going to have
to do I'm just going to say relative to
where the index is two so that's that's
going to get the 77 so 33 + 77
is uh on the spot 37 is 10 so that gives
me a four here so with a zero uh 4 + 7
is 10 isn't it 10 no
yes no oh my gosh it's 110 there we are
okay so we get 110
out never do this live I I wrote These
numbers down beforehand and I should
have like put the intermedi I let all
the bits out and it'll look really slck
I look I look like I'm clever but no you
don't have to edit them out everyone can
tell me like this is why we have
computers to do this for us yeah yeah
this is it so 110 doesn't fit into our
two digits so we're left with just the
10 at the bottom but our carry flag is
now raised so somewhere and I I meant to
make some little cocktail stick Flags to
stick up but so Sean hold up a little
flag for me yeah they're going to have
to like do this right hang on hang on
there we are amazing in fact that's
supposed to be a c one stage I had a
flag like that on my desk which was an
interrupt flag where people would raise
it to say I'd like to interrupt
interrupt your work yeah exactly which
we could talk about another time anyway
so we've got 10 carry one so we remember
the carry now we're going to store that
10 which is the bottom part of our
result in x + 4 which is you know not 1
2 3 4 so we're going to put 10 in this
box fantastic but now we have to do the
next part of the calculation and add the
most significant Parts together so so
I'm going to just quickly write this out
x + 1 add with carry at x + 3
store at x + 5 so working that through
we're going to load the two so our
accumulator now has 02 in it and now
we're going to add the three which would
give us five but the carry flag is set
so we also increment it by another one
that gives us six and is that carry flag
does it is it always GNA be a one am I
being a full here is it always no
absolutely yes there's if you if you
think about what's the largest two
numbers that you could add together it's
99 and 99 and so the the largest amount
you could ever carry is exactly 100 into
the next yes okay I see I see yeah I
know what you mean it feels like you
should need more information doing the
columns sometimes there was maybe an
eight going AC no there wasn't there's
always no that was yeah no I was just
doing long long IC
wrong that's why you were confused it's
all right I'm back with you so we've got
06 in here so now we've got 233 +
377 is
610 which I really do hope is the next
correct Fibonacci number so that's super
cool right and you could see how we
could extend that arbitrarily to say
well I want to have 10 digigit numbers
or 100 digigit numbers or so on and so
forth but pragmatically um we pick one
two four maybe eight bytes to make a
number together and in modern computers
they can store more than two digits at
once in fact that's what makes a modern
computer so modern is like the 8 bit or
the 16 bit or 32 or 64 bit n of the
computer is how many digits it can
naturally deal with before it has to
start carrying and moving around but you
can still build these things out um
using those those operations but the
other sort of key thing about this is
that finally now if you we we can
finally we can stop calculating
Fibonacci numbers once we've reached the
biggest one we can store right because
if we teach our robot one more trick so
if you remember that in our Fibonacci
Sequence at the end of this route the
part where we' added the two together we
would move the index on to the next
number now we need to move it forward
two slots to account for the fact that
each number takes up two slots and then
we would just jump back to the top and
do it again so we just keep repeating
that forever and ever and ever and ever
and ever and ever which is great right
up until it wrote to the the the boxes
the pigeon holes that contained The Very
program that we were executing in which
case you know horrible things would
happen but what we can do now is we can
say if we teach the robot look you can
jump conditionally so it's a maybe jump
and we say jump back round so I'm going
to say branch which is another way
saying jump Branch if the carry is clear
back to the top of the loop which I
haven't drawn but the loop is up here
somewhere and there's some bits missing
here as well it's not important but this
means that instead of always jumping
this is like only jump if the carry is
still clear and the carry would only be
clear here if the last piece of
arithmetic with the high numbers hadn't
also needed yet another bite another
another value and so as soon as we get
to was it 10,000 it would stop and say
yeah okay this is not representable
anymore I can't fit it and then we would
say you know stop here or I would say
RTS which would say turn sub routine in
this language which means go back to
doing whatever you were doing before or
halt or something like that and so now
our robot can stop yeah and also you
know um you could understand how uh if
you wanted to uh do other sort of
comparisons you could use arithmetic
operations so for example if you wanted
to do something until two numbers were
equal to each other which is quite
common you just subtract the two numbers
that you're interested in and then if
the answer is zero the zero flag is set
and so that would give me a way of
discriminate you could say JUMP Branch
if the zero flag is set that means the
two numbers I just subtracted are the
same and then similarly if you want to
say if one's bigger than the other if
you subtract a from B and B is bigger
than a then the answer you get is
negative so that negative flag will be
set and so you can do all these things
all those comparisons and all the other
things that you need to do to sort of do
some form of control flow can be built
out of the perimeters we've got here
cool now one last thing I wanted to show
and that is to sort of say that like I
have been slowly morphing what I've been
writing down here from a sort of madeup
instruction for a madeup computer into
something which looks to most folks a
little bit familiar well not some some
folks a little familiar and so what I'd
like to show just at the end here is if
I flick this button over here what we
have here is a BBC micro running a very
slightly tweaked version of the
Fibonacci code here okay and in fact
I've got it to also print out the the uh
uh machine code that the human readable
human readable I mean it's as readable
as as we can get so if you can see at
the top here the first few lines here
are setting up the first two Fibonacci
numbers are
001 or 0 1 0 I should say sorry getting
the right way around and then there is a
whole bunch of code here that looks
similar load and add and store load and
add and store increment and then Branch
around this is showing you that a 1980s
computer works pretty much exactly the
way that we described here and the I
actually the the boxes that I chose to
write the Fibonacci numbers in actually
are the boxes that correspond to the
picture on the screen which is why at
the very top of the screen you can see
this sort of junky color stuff that is
in fact the Fibonacci sequence being
interpreted by the video Hardware okay
now being an emulator I can actually
quickly pop in and tell tell the system
I can go and look directly in the pigeon
holes 7
CS I can't see my computer as the screen
at the same time so now we've looked at
the pigeon hole addresses at 7 c00 now
again I was doing everything in sort of
a decimal version of a computer these
are now in HEX so if you just forgive
the hexad decimal we can see that 0 1 0
0 0 1 0 0 there's the first two numbers
02 0 0 03 0 0 05 08 0 D that's 13 and so
on and somewhere in there we will find
the hex representation of 610 if we do
it right but there are the actual pigeon
holes in a real computer real real from
the 1980s computer an emulated real
computer in and emulated running in a
web browser of all things so yeah you
know we've really come full circle here
each of these bits has the number
associated with it so this would be
considered Bit Zero and this would be
considered bit 31 and then we can count
down so this is then B so sometimes the
way this is done by some in